depuis plusieurs mois le rappeur booba
mène un combat contre ce qu'on appelle
les influenceurs
cette gaffe ou lancés sur les réseaux
sociaux il dénonce presque chaque jour
les pratiques commerciales douteuses de
ces célébrités d'internet qu'il accuse
d'escroquerie
et c'est trop bien
dans une interview accordée au journal
libération il montre sa détermination
ils ont tué des citoyens en leur vendant
des saloperies leur délire là le drop
shipping c'est révoltant il faut que
leur monde totalement fake tombe
mis en cause par le rappeur le drop
shipping et les agentes influence le
drop shipping une technique utilisée par
les influenceurs pour vendre des
produits souvent issus de chine est de
mauvaise qualité à leurs abonnés et à
des tarifs bien trop élevé pour
tout comprendre nous recevons ce soir
notre témoin du jour maître patrick
klugman l'avocat de booba dans cette
affaire
merci patrick bateman d'être avec nous
j'ai rencontré ce midi en plus par
hasard branché dans le même restaurant
merci pour l'invitation ce que je
voudrais payer mais quelques sushis vous
êtes l'avocat douba on va parler d'une
affaire sérieuse mais juste avant que
vous exprimer c'est vrai qu'on a vu
beaucoup beaucoup de vidéos de personnes
qui disent s'être fait arnaquer par des
influenceurs regarder on vous a fait une
compil pour voir voilà ce qui se dit
qu'elles sont voilà quels sont les
objets les objets de cette arnaque un
vrai les gens qui disent ne pas avoir
recevoir les produits que ce sont des
produits voilà qui peuvent être nocifs
pour la santé regardez on a même été
voir une personne qui se dit être
victime de ses produits vendus par les
influenceurs qui est un aspirateur de
points noirs la sensation est assez
douloureuse ça fait plutôt mal quand on
l'appliqué mais c'est clairement pas
magique je ne conseille absolument pas
ce produit les trains partant intérieur
voilà nous sommes pris pour des pigeons
mais excusez moi packaging ya rien un
truc transparent avec 1 tout collant
collée dessus c'est un carnage la vie de
ma mère que ça j'ai acheté des collants
j'ai rentré ma grosses cuisses dedans je
les fais délicatement l'on doit bien
compris comme ça dans le collant de
grosse arnaque à l'épée d'arnaquer les
gens à 30 bal voilà alors on a également
je vous dis une jeune personne qu'on est
allé voir voilà et qui vient s'appelle
abla qui a pris rendez vous dans le
salon de coiffure d'une influence euse
lancer la promotion on a perdu 500 euros
est beaucoup plus que ça regardez ce
qu'a dit tu m'avais la blache chefs
d'entreprise et j'estime que j'ai été
victime d'une injustice
même voire d'une arnaque chez un
coiffeur ya à peu près un peu plus de
deux ans j'ai je tombais sur un live
qu'elle faisait sur les réseaux sociaux
sur le choix c'était sur instagram les
conséquences du lissage des le premier
shampooing c'est à dire trois jours
après mes cheveux se tomber en masse
donc j'ai eu très peur sur le moment je
me suis dit c'est les effets du lissage
ça va passer je commençais à ne plus
avoir de cheveux du tout j'ai perdu plus
de la moitié de mes cheveux c'est
vraiment malhonnête comme comportement
c'est vraiment malhonnête alors la
question qu'on se pose patrick de bones
et les influenceurs sont ils des escrocs
après avec tout ce qu'on entend de
petites minutes alors déjà qu'est ce qui
se passe calais c'est quoi la faire
vraiment
expliqué nous pour nos téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent j'avais influenceurs
c'est qu'ils sont les influenceurs sont
des gens qui ont une influence ou ça sur
les réseaux sociaux et aux réseaux
sociaux on sait que c'est le seul où
principal vecteur de culture d'intérêt
notamment de la jeunesse les
influenceurs y en a de toutes sortes moi
je pense qu'on peut pas je devrais vous
dire oui évidemment je pense qu'on veut
pas jeter tout le monde on peut pas
jeter tout les bébé avec l'eau du bain
il ya des pâtissiers qui se servent des
réseaux sociaux pour se faire connaître
heureusement il ya des décorateurs des
architectes voir des médecins même qui
se sert de ça pour faire connaître pour
faire des recommandations à partir de
cela un système s'est créé un système
commercial secret et qui utilise alors
ce qui intéressait booba
ce sont en fait les influenceurs issus
de la télé réalité qu'est ce qui donne
un bon bah bah il dénonce le fait que
des personnes se servent de la de leur
notoriété pour vend n'importe quoi à
n'importe qui et c'est pas juste une
star de la télé réalité à qui tout de
suite on va la prendre en main on va lui
créer un compte on va même créé des
abonnés et puis on va lui faire vendre
des produits que souvent elle même ne
connaît absolument pas mais puisqu'elle
a un crédit auprès de ses followers et
avant de ses spectateurs eh bien les
gens vont acheter parfois se ruiner
parce qu'on est sur une population
crédules fragile ce sont nos jeunes ce
sont nos enfants parfois ces nouveaux
spectateurs sur bien sûr et qui savent
pas se réguler par rapport à ça et
puisqu'il ya quelqu'un qui en qu'ils ont
confiance quelqu'un qui connaissent
quelqu'un qui fait partie de leur
quotidien que les produisons des sceaux
cheikh mbaye on m'a dit aussi voilà
parfois ont parfois les produits peuvent
être un produit à 19 ans dans le pub
dans le grand public et pour le grand
public et qui est vendu à un phénomène
où on appelle le drop shipping up c'est
quoi si vous avez une personnalité qui
est pas un commerçant mais qui va vous
vend des produits en réalité le drop
shipping c'est quoi ils nous voient un
produit qu'elle n'a pas de là deux
possibilités
parfois vous envoyez votre argent sur un
site que vous ne connaissez pas et rien
ne se passe argent perdu et puis elle
phénomène un peu intermédiaire qui
étaient dénoncées dans votre reportage
syrie où vous avez commandé un produit
vous l'avez payé très cher et vous
recevez un truc qui n'a absolument rien
à voir ou qui n'a pas l'utilité qui
était prévu outin dans le produit ne
correspond ni à son utilité ni à son
prix ça s'appelle une pratique
commerciale trompeuse c'est ça alors il
ya des téléspectateurs qui n'a pas quand
on reçoit pas le produit s'est pas
illégal mais c'est immoral en fait c'est
ça annonce est illégale alors même
canton parce que quand on vend un
produit qu'on le reçoit est-ce que c'est
illégal alors c'est illégal vous avez
finalement tout s'est réglé par quoi
salué par un coach et le code de la
consommation et le code de la
consommation c'est pas très difficile à
suivre on est à lire il ya un catalogue
de tout ce qui se passe quand on
commande un produit sur internet un
catalogue ces articles 121 1 et suivants
c'est hyper bien fait et vous voyez que
soi quand on vous vend un produit
associé soit quand on vous trompe sur le
prude ou sur le produit soit qu on vous
trompe sur la qualité du produit soit
sur son prix et bien tout ça c'est une
pratique commerciale trompeuse et c'est
un délit pénal et ça peut être puni
d'une peine d'amendé ou même d'une peine
d'emprisonnement
et cette peine d'emprisonnement quand
elle est commise en bande organisée elle
peut aller je crois même jusqu'à sept
ans alors donc je peux aller en prison
puisque comme
si vous violer la loi va et c'est vrai
comme circuler sur les réseaux sociaux
je fais partie d'un groupe d'audiovisuel
dans lequel je suis voilà petit
actionnaire et c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'on est on est donc l
actionnaire et propriétaire d'une des
sociétés qui n'a pas le choix d'un event
donc une des sociétés qui pratiquent
donc voilà ses ventes avec les
influenceurs donc est-ce qu'on est ce
qu'on risque quelque chose alors je peux
pas vous faire une consultation gratuite
parce que vraiment alors jaser contrôle
j'ai un petit peu de souffle et on se
faire un peu d'argent sur moi non mais
non mais non est ce que c'est donc un
non mais alors la société shona rubens
elle a été mise en cause en l'occurrence
puisque la suite nationale 26 la société
qui dirigé par magali des abats et
magali baba se présente comme le
principal agent d'affluence eux étant
elle même à travers ces influenceurs
dont elle s'occupe de la carrière que
elle même directement par exemple elle
même à la fée de l'avant de deux
formations se pouvant être financé par
le comte de professionnels de formation
donc tant elle même que ces influenceurs
ont été mis en cause pourquoi parce que
derrière des produits qu'elle a fait
qu'elle a vendues dont elle a fait la
promotion il y avait deux l' abus et
nous enfin booba a même créé une boîte
mail s'appelle influent voleurs il a
demandé à sa fanbase et à tous ceux qui
leur toute dernière envoyez moi tout ce
que vous avez à dire et sur ces
influenceurs et on a eu en fait
énormément de choses qui concernent les
chemins events qui concernait plus
spécifiquement il ya d'autres sociétés
nous ce qu'on a reçu oui oui mais oui on
va orienter un pareil 1 voilà c'est
pareil probablement et je vous dirais
qu'ils sont très bons à quelque chose un
vote mais avoue s les blacks est pareil
non non il n'y a pas fait dénonciation à
chennai munch pas quoi on a fait quelque
chose de plus large on a aussi beaucoup
de choses non mais ça veut pas dire
qu'il ya que jeunes arrivés sur place
mais en tout cas ce que je peux vous
dire une chose je suis permis d'appeler
way le directeur général de smile tu me
dis qu'on a eu énormément de contrôle et
que à chaque fois ils n'ont pas vu de
failles et nous ne sommes pas dans
l'illégalité nous on a reçu sur ce mail
là que j'ai exploité qui a donné une
saisine de la dgccrf c'est une autorité
administrative qui protège les
consommateurs et une saisine du
procureur et public ils nous ont dit que
des enquêtes étaient déjà en cours que
des enquêtes étaient ouvertes une
révélation que je vous fais donc la
société jaune à evans est sous enquête
pénale et de la dgccrf et j'ai bien
compris que nous n'étions pas les seuls
à avoir alerté les autorités sur les
pratiques de l'association knives ce qui
veut bien dire non à mayol évidemment
que d'autres sont en cause mais vu que
c'est le leader moi je vais vous dire si
magali berne a été sincère le message et
c'est ce que vous me dites est exact que
riz non merci ont fait le ménage sur le
marché si comme vous le dites la cité
jeunesse à la mairie après tout ce que
vous allez faire le ménage et c'est très
bien un
leader sur un marché qui est critiquée
elle devrait nous remercier la demande
et à l'erreur
elle devrait très de coder et au
contraire on voit bien que plus on
l'accusé sur des choses très documenté
donc il ya eu les les phénomènes quand
même c'est extrêmement grave la
chirurgie esthétique on a vendu à des
gamines des prestations de chirurgie
esthétique ça a été n'importe quoi non
parle quand même de santé publique après
il ya les crème épilatoire qui sont
mensongers ou dangereuses après il ya
toutes sortes d'appareils bon c'est des
petits treizistes parfois pour les gens
qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent donc
entre la santé publique d'un côté et des
gens qui se seront truffe et qui n'osent
pas porter plainte parce que dénoncer un
influenceur c'est prendre le risque de
se voir flashé sur un réseau social par
quelqu'un qui a parfois comme vous
peut-être des centaines de milliers de
followers donc les gens ont peur
personne ne dit rien donc là moi je dis
heureusement que c'est trouver booba est
franchement n'est pas très modérée par
la peur qui a vu ce truc qu'il l'a pris
en main qui l'a pris en grippe on aura
des maras et et qui a décidé de dénoncer
avec toutes les conséquences pour lui ça
peut avoir c'est retrouver à son tour
accusé de toutes sortes de choses de
cyber harcèlement par malaga gardien
carrasso les villages et hocine pas bon
enfin qu'ils étaient reçus il a été
accusé et mais c'est pas quelqu'un qui a
peur et si vous lui posez la question
tout à l'heure je pense qu'il est très
fier de chasse qu'il a fait c'est son
mode de fonctionnement il trouve des
combats qui lui parce que moi j'ai
dénoncée moi je veux pas du tout ça je
vous dis la vérité
les conseils du jeu énormément booba au
téléphone voilà on a beaucoup échangé
tous les deux et je lui ai dit vraiment
moi je suis pas du tout tout ça c'est
vrai que voilà nous avec mes associés on
s'occupe pas du tout de ce qui se passe
sur les influenceurs etc et c'est lui
qui m'a alerté qui m'a dit regarde quand
même ce qui se passe et ce qui se
passera donc chez j'ai commencé à me
dire ok tout voilà exactement moi aussi
mais nous aussi voilà on fait comme on y
voit là on gouverne en interne mais bon
je serais partisan comme actionnaire je
serai prudent je poserai des questions
dans ce qu'on fait c'est pour pour
l'instant pour l'instant on voudrait
prudent me répond que tout va bien bah
je vous le dis non mais je dis parce que
j'ai pas un cadeau que j'ai dit ah bon
bah je vais je vais demander je vais
poser des questions mais et sachez que
quand on a repris voilà quand ils ont
repris c'est vrai que mon ami voilà on a
mis un quelqu'un qui s'en occupe et qui
apparemment me dis que je vous donne
aurait touché quand moi mes clients
habituels les entreprises tpe font
l'objet d'une crise ou d'une mise en
cause publique après ce qu'on fait c'est
pour qu'on vous appelle avant même de
nous défendre de défendre on vous font
dirigeants des enquêtes internes tout ça
pour savoir en interne ce qui se passe
exactement da des cabinets indépendants
qui font des investigations parfois plus
strictes et policiers est honteux pèsent
sur komlan garda est fait ça je vous
donnerai une recommande donc acheter un
truc je vous dirais je voudrais les
résultats de l'enquêté interne avec
devrais je voudrais en plus moi voilà
comme j'ai dit non non on a un groupe
vraiment produire autant koh lanta que
28 minutes que les marseillais c'est
comme les programmes moi qui ai des
programmes voilà dans lesquels sur
lesquels on et voilà on est producteur
sur lesquels je suis pas je sais pas
très fan mais voilà c'est vrai que voilà
on est on est pas partout et c'est vrai
qu'on a je me suis penché un petit peu
sur cette affaire suite
que se bâtit booba qui est voilà qui est
un pote et puis voilà qui maquille ma
voix et je me suis dit c'est mon pote me
dit ça m'a dit de regarder on va
regarder maintenant d'entrain on est en
train de deux ans d'enquêté là dessus
mais c'est vrai que voilà moi je pense
aussi à notre public et et mon public
voilà j'ai pas envie qu'ils subissent
sur la d d d arnaque il a chez qui
on et booba n'est pas le seul à le dire
il l'a dit d'une manière extrêmement
claire franche courageuse il y a pris
des risques il n'y a rien n'a rien rien
pardon et gagner mais ça c'est sa
personnalité mais maintenant on ait été
suivi par le ministre de l'économie et
des finances par tout un tas de gens et
heureusement que tout le monde s'y mette
bas on va toutes façons le marché va
être nettoyé vérité me suis rassis
magali béaba et schnyder devant mais je
vive aux grandes et les moyennes marché
je trouve ça très très bien je le dis je
suis pour voilà ce qu'il en est j'ai la
justice et aux affaires à géraldine
celle de booba
ah oui parce que le fossat de francs est
ce que vous aimeriez qu'ils vous
invitent au stade de france boulevard
vraiment oui non mais bon on va lui
demander s'il a envie de vous inviter le
domaine puisque booba est avec nous ça
va mon goût
fais gaffe fais gaffe quand même comment
ça va
je t'attends mal aimé ben oui qu'est ce
que tu as vu gérad elle a très bien géré
a dit géraldine ne veut pas venir à ton
concert
est ce que tu as envie est-ce que tu
avais envie d'inviter toi
huawei devrait venir pourquoi est ce que
ça donne n'a pas envie de venir pour moi
ce que ça donne
qu'est ce qu'il ya grâce que c'est le
talent bon tu es prêt pour le stade de
france ou pas
et
80000 personnes
sans sponsor sans rien théorie ou pas
très heureux
que tu dis tu vas tu va rouler comme un
temps là
[Rires]
les enfants je vais chercher des infos
je
t'entends on t'entend hyper mal qu'est
ce que tu peux nous dire ce soir
on vous dira qu' on va se faire
et merci d'avoir dénoncé le non match et
le combat
et est ce qui t'a dit tout le monde au
stade de france
attendent entre maria q
enfin la fête on va boire à abidjan dont
wayne berda ces mots
de l'ormeau ces noms déjà à
[Rires]
bercy talent dit m castaldi aux fausses
ouais en face à
zéro
a dit ne veut pas venir ouais dit au bio
oui
alors le reste c'est bon ça va super bon
gars c'est là sa mission
je serai là samedi soir et toute la
famille tu le sais inch'allah ouais je
pense que ça va être bon tu m'as millet
déplaçant faux sociale je te fais un
gros bisou cas on a bien
battu la no quand je t'embrasse fort et
je viens de voir samedi soir
[Applaudissements]